esta vez vamos a trazar una curva donde
nuestra coordenada x y no esta
coordenada james sean funciones de un
tercer parámetro t entonces podemos
decir que x es una función de t y
también podemos decir que james es una
función de t si esto te es completamente
desconocido te encargo que veas los
vídeos de ecuaciones paramétricas en
khan academy de lo que quiero hablar y
vamos a pensarlo en forma general en
vídeos futuros hablaremos de una manera
más concreta en algunos ejemplos ahora
lo que quiero es que pensemos en cuál es
la trayectoria o el camino que traza
esta función desde te iguala por lo
tanto aquí voy a tener el punto x de am
ideam perfecto y vamos desde ese punto
donde t es igual a am hasta el punto de
iguala ver no sé
imaginemos que mi curva hace algo más o
menos así entonces aquí tenemos el punto
cuando te es igual a b es decir el punto
x de bmw y pensemos en cómo podemos
encontrar la longitud de arco de esta
curva
bueno para obtenerla vamos a hacer un
acercamiento y pensar en qué es lo que
está pasando cuando tomamos un cambio
muy pequeño en t así que imagina que
empezamos en este punto de aquí y
tenemos un cambio muy pequeño en t así
que vamos de este punto a este otro
punto es decir sobre un camino muy
pequeño el tema y de hecho este cambio
debería ser más pequeño pero si fuera
más pequeño tendrás problemas en verlo
así que supongamos que este es mi
pequeño cambio en tema de nuestra
trayectoria y por lo tanto queremos
encontrar esta longitud bueno podemos
descomponerlo en cuanto nos movemos en
dirección x y en cuanto nos movemos en
dirección jeff así que en dirección x
nos movemos con un cambio muy pequeño en
x ya que será igual este cambio bueno
este será la tasa de cambio de x con
respecto a t por un pequeño cambio en t
y yo sé que esto es poco riguroso ya que
estoy usando una anotación diferencial
conceptualmente estoy usando la idea de
diferencial común
infinitesimalmente pequeño en esta
variable pero esta no es una prueba
formal sin embargo nos va a dar la
intuición de cómo podemos derivar una
longitud de arco cuando estás trabajando
con ecuaciones paramétricas así que
espero que esto te dé la intuición de
que este es nuestro de x / dt que
podemos escribir también como x prima de
t y a esto lo estoy multiplicando por dt
y ahora para nuestro cambio james vamos
a tener la misma idea nuestro cambio
infinitesimalmente pequeño el tiempo lo
podemos ver como el cambio en que con
respecto a t por nuestro pequeño cambio
en t de t
es decir esto es igual a ye prima de t
por de tema y bueno basándonos en esto
como podemos escribir este pequeño
cambio en nuestra longitud de arco bueno
para ello podemos usar nuestro teorema
de pitágoras ya que esta longitud de
arco es simplemente la hipotenusa de
este triángulo rectángulo entonces será
la raíz cuadrada de de x al cuadrado más
d al cuadrado o lo podemos escribir de
la siguiente manera como la raíz
cuadrada de x prima de t por de t esto
elevado al cuadrado más que prima de t
por dtm esto también elevado al cuadrado
y ahora intentemos simplificar un poco
esta expresión recuerda estamos hablando
de cambios infinitesimalmente pequeños
por aquí así que podemos factorizar un
dt al cuadrado de aquí porque es un
factor común en ambos suman dos y
entonces me va a quedar la raíz 4
de éste dt al cuadrado así que déjame
ponerlo al principio observa esto va a
ser igual a la raíz cuadrada de dt al
cuadrado que multiplica a su vez a x
prima de t esto elevado al cuadrado más
10 prima de t
esto también elevado al cuadrado hay que
ser claros el dt elevado al cuadrado
multiplica los dos suman 2 por lo tanto
ahora puedo simplemente sacarlo de este
radical así que todo esto me va a quedar
como la raíz cuadrada de x prima de tema
esto elevado al cuadrado más de prima de
t
esto elevado al cuadrado ya todo esto lo
estoy multiplicando por de t
al final sacamos este dt del radical
bien podría ponerlo en un principio pero
creo que queda mucho mejor hasta el
final así que multiplican a estos dos y
ahora esto que acabamos de encontrar es
simplemente una forma de reescribir la
expresión para este pequeño cambio
infinitesimal en esta longitud de arco
para nuestra suerte en cálculo obtenemos
herramientas para sumar todos los
cambios infinitesimalmente pequeños ya
que eso es justo lo que hace la integral
definida así que si queremos sumar todos
los cambios esté más se esté más este
más extremas este ojo recuerda que son
cambios infinitesimalmente pequeños no
los estoy mostrando tan
infinitesimalmente pequeños pero esto
nos sirve para poder pensar en estos
cambios si queremos sumar todos estos
principalmente lo que tenemos que hacer
es tomar la integral y como estamos
integrando con respecto a tema entonces
será desde t igual a am hasta t igual a
b y así es como obtenemos al menos una
forma conceptual la fórmula para
encontrar la longitud de arco cuando
estamos trabajando con ecuaciones
paramétricas así que en los siguientes
vídeos aplicaremos esta fórmula de
longitud de arco en algunos ejemplos así
que nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo